MALE SPEAKER: You're here
because of asteroids and
Jason, who comes out of NASA's
headquarters in DC, at 300
East Street, I understand.
JASON KESSLER: Southwest.
MALE SPEAKER: Southwest.
Anyway, so Jason's come here to
speak with us about finding
and planning for asteroids that
may squash us like bugs
or like other species who have
been squashed in the past.
JASON KESSLER: And thanks
for the invite.
What a great opportunity.
We announced the Asteroid Grand
Challenge back in June,
and it's a new way of thinking
and doing business at NASA.
So it's a great privilege.
This will be the first public
audience since the
announcement that I've gotten
the chance to speak to.
So, thank you.
Space for a long time has
captivated our imagination.
And through space exploration,
we have the ability to
radically change our future
and, at the same time, do
things for the benefit
of all of humankind.
About a little over 65 million
years ago, there was a very
bad day here on planet Earth.
And these poor folks didn't
really have any ability to do
anything about it.
And really what I'm here to
talk about is a natural
disaster that we actually
have the ability to
do something about.
We can change our fate.
And it really only requires
the will to do so.
This is not new.
It happened over 65
million years ago.
But it happens more often than
I think people ever realized.
Earlier this year, in February,
the 15th of
February, we were anxiously
watching DA14 pass by--
very close asteroid
pass of the Earth.
And then lo and behold,
out of the sun,
comes a 17 meter asteroid.
It hits in Chelyabinsk,
Russia.
You can see here a crater from
a 50 meter asteroid, the
remains of which are in
Northern Arizona--
the equivalent of 10
megatons of TNT.
So this stuff happens.
One need only look at the
surface of the moon.
We're in a very, very active
neighborhood, statistically.
Folks might say the likelihood
is small.
But the reality is that we don't
know where that many of
these smaller asteroids
are located.
So NASA announced with the
FY14 budget an Asteroid
Initiative.
So to give you a sense of how
this fits into the overall
NASA program, NASA
has an overall
strategy to study asteroids.
They're very interesting
for lots of reasons--
origins of life, origins of the
solar system, planetary
defense, resources for here
on Earth or exploration.
And so NASA's had a whole
lot going on in
the asteroid realm.
But in '14, we announced two
aspects of an Asteroid
Initiative.
The first, which you've probably
heard quite a bit
about, is the idea that we would
find a 7 to 10-meter
non-threatening asteroid, send
a spacecraft through a solar
electric propulsion system out
to this asteroid, capture that
asteroid, redirect it around
the moon in a trans-lunar
orbit, and then send humans on
the SLS Orion program that we
are currently building at NASA
to go explore it and bring
samples back.
It got a lot of press
early in the year--
the excitement of sending humans
to go and explore a
body that hasn't been
touched before.
The other aspect, though, and
the one I'm going to focus on
today is the Asteroid
Grand Challenge.
And that is focusing on the
potentially hazardous threats
that every single human being
and every life form on this
planet ought to have
some interest in.
So digging down a little bit
more deeply into the Asteroid
Initiative, we see that there
are a couple of areas of
overlap between the Grand
Challenge and the mission.
In terms of detection--
absolutely have to
find a target for
humans to go and explore.
While at the same time, we
have to find what is
threatening out there
and might impact us.
So there's overlap between the
two aspects in detection.
And then the second, maybe not
as obvious to folks, is that
when you go out and explore,
you're going to have to have
proximity operations.
You're going to have to learn
how to operate around this
foreign object.
The same type of knowledge might
be useful in terms of a
mitigation solution.
Are you dealing with an asteroid
that a gravity
tractor might work, where you
have a mass that helps pull,
slowly nudge, this threatening
asteroid off of its course and
thereby saving the planet
from getting impacted?
So there's some obvious
areas of overlap.
Additionally, the Grand
Challenges is focusing on
engaging a community that we
don't normally talk with.
NASA has a tradition of getting
a mission, having
requirements for that mission,
executing to those
requirements through either
grants and contracts that are
let with a community
that we typically
work pretty well with.
The twist here, and one that I
can say, thanks to Ames, the
neighbor just down the road from
here and the NASA Center
that really does push the
envelope in terms of
partnership and participatory
engagement, is that we have an
opportunity to speak with folks
that we don't normally
talk with about these kinds of
things and start to pull in
ideas that we wouldn't
have before.
And I'll give some examples
of what that looks like.
In a scale this bigger
that's new for NASA.
So here we are with the actual
challenge statement.
And you can see that
it is grand.
It's bigger than NASA's ability
to handle on its own.
Finding all asteroid threats
to human populations and
knowing what to do about
them, that's even
really beyond our mission.
In terms of mitigation
and deflecting,
that's not our bailiwick.
But what the Grand Challenge
enables us to do is take an
area that we do a lot of work
in and start a conversation
broadly, a global conversation
at that, and invite others
into help with this effort,
because as I said, this is an
issue that every life form on
the planet should have some
interest in.
So the way we're addressing this
Grand Challenges is in
five areas.
Detection--
we have to find where
they are.
Tracking--
we've got to know what their
orbits are so that, once you
find it, you need to
know, is it on a
path to hit the planet?
Characterization--
what's its spin rate?
What's its size?
What's it shape?
And then, as you start to move
into some of the other
interesting aspects of
asteroids, what's it made of?
What kind of materials
might be there?
Is there water, a fuel
source for deeper
exploration, minerals?
And then finally--
mitigation.
Once we find something that's on
its way, we need to figure
out, out of the multiple choices
that we have now, how
do we deflect it and mitigate
its impact?
And then woven throughout
all four aspects is a
communication piece, because
thanks to Hollywood, there are
some wild ideas on how one
might solve this problem.
And part of this effort is to
communicate clearly what is
factual and what solutions
might work.
So to dig in a little bit more
deeply, if you look at that
circle, there is a chunk
of the circle
that's not filled in.
The rest of that circle, those
are slices of people that are
already doing work.
NASA's doing a lot
of work to find
potentially hazardous asteroids.
Starting in '98, we've had
a very serious program.
The Near-Earth Object
Observation Program has found
over 95% of the 1-kilometer
or larger asteroids.
Those are the planet killers.
The challenge is that we're only
finding about a thousand
a year, and there are
potentially a million out
there, down to 30 meters
or larger.
And as I said earlier,
Chelyabinsk that hit in
Russia, that was 17 meters--
about a thousand people
seriously hurt, windows blown
out, millions of dollars
worth of damage.
So we're looking for roughly
twice that size, because that
could really devastate a city.
So there's opportunity here to
build upon the work that we're
already doing.
We recognize there's a need.
So beyond just external
contributors to this effort,
there are potential
contributors.
And in fact, the third listed
there is Maker Community.
It's a new one for NASA
to think about.
I'm off to Maker Faire in New
York City this weekend.
And I know that Ames has had
a big presence at the Maker
Faire here and have been
engaging with folks about a
conversation--
are there ways that we can
improve mirror grinding?
Are there ways that
we can improve
telescope mount builds?
Can we redesign, re-engineer?
Can we lower the cost of
what it takes to build
ground-based detection?
I mentioned Hollywood
earlier as well.
I'm very pleased to say that
there's some serious interest
in focusing on a very
factually-based asteroid film.
And so in terms of the
communication piece, to be
able to explain to folks what's
really at stake here
and what really do we have the
ability to do at this point
and what is that gap that we
need to start filling--
an interesting opportunity to
partner there, to bring
science fiction and
science fact a
little bit closer together.
An example of partnership
potential here--
light curve analysis is
really hard to do.
You need to be patient, and
you need to have telescope
time with the equipment to be
able to track a quickly-moving
asteroid through the night sky
throughout the night, because,
basically, what you're
doing here is
you've got your telescope.
And you've got a CCD
taking images.
And over time, you're
determining the change in the
reflected light.
The albedo changes over time.
You can start to get a sense
of what the spin rate is.
Eventually, you can figure
out what the shape of the
asteroid may be.
Mathematically difficult--
it takes, again, a lot
of telescope time.
And so as we focused our energy
into detection, because
that's the first problem we need
to solve, it's expensive
to spend time on those
telescopes tracking and
characterizing.
So there are about 50 to 100
amateur astronomers that are
doing near-Earth asteroid
light curve analysis.
So as I stepped into this
program, I saw this is an
immediate place that we can
change the conversation.
You can get a published paper
out of the work that you do on
a light curve analysis.
So by broadening this
conversation and saying to
folks, we've got a
serious problem.
We'd like your help
addressing.
we'll collaborate with you to
figure out how to make light
curve analysis either easier
or more accessible, and you
can contribute meaningfully to
this cause and potentially get
a published paper out of it.
So as a first step to build off
of the momentum that we're
creating, engaging university
students is one of the first
things that we are
looking at doing.
Shape model--
I mentioned characterization.
Shape models are also tough.
It's not an easy problem.
And so, is there a way to throw
a challenge out to a
community and say, here's
our requirement.
Here is the state of
the art right now.
Can you help us?
A technique of using the prize
and challenge authority that
NASA has to engage folks with
the potential of getting some
prize money if not great
recognition.
And then finally, as an obvious
next step, would be
space-based observation.
I believe Ed Lu from the B612
Foundation was here previously
and is coming back
later this month.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
November 4.
JASON KESSLER: November 4--
come see Ed.
B612 has got a plan to send an
infrared telescope up into a
Venus-trailing orbit and
radically improve the number
of asteroids that we can
discover each year.
And so space-based observation
really would enable us to get
to a place where we can increase
our detection rate
and enable us to find those that
are getting smaller, down
to the 30-meter size, because
30 meters is tough.
I said we've found 95% of the
1 kilometer or larger, and
we've had an amateur
help with that.
The difficulty, though now, is
that as you get smaller,
they're fainter.
They're moving fast.
And to expect the amateur
community to help us with
detection is really not very
realistic at this point.
And so that's why we focused on
light curve analysis as a
way to engage the amateur
community to help here.
But it's really getting into
space that will enable us
24-hour viewing.
It'll get us away from the sun
and keep that blind spot from
impacting our ability
to search.
Does that mean that there might
be small sat solutions?
We were talking a little bit
earlier at Ames with some of
the folks there about small sat
solutions for observation.
And in fact, just had somebody
pop up with an idea of using
space station as a
platform as well.
So space-based observation is
really the next phase for us
to get serious about our
detection effort.
I mentioned Ed and the
B612 foundation.
This is one example that we
anticipate using at NASA to
engage the community.
Here's a public-private
partnership.
We have an unfunded Space Act
Agreement that's a legal
agreement between NASA
and private entity.
In this case, it's a nonprofit
whose mission is very well
aligned with NASA's.
And the idea is that, through a
Space Act Agreement, through
this partnership mechanism, you
have a shared future that
you'd like to see become real,
and you align your expertise
and contribute accordingly.
And so NASA provides some
science and engineering
support as well as the use of
the Deep Space Network to
receive data from the
mission that they
have proposed to fly.
So the Space Act agreement is
a great mechanism for us to
look to other organizations to
partner with and enable a
collaboration that's beneficial
for both.
I mentioned briefly prizes.
So NASA has prize authority, a
pretty special opportunity for
us to have no-year money.
For those that aren't familiar
with the government budget
cycle, it usually has
two-year life.
But prizes can take
quite a long time.
And so we have the ability
to have some funds
that wouldn't expire.
And so here you see an
image a Centennial
Challenge prize winner.
This was the Green
Flight Challenge.
And the challenge it was to fly
200 miles in less than two
hours and less than a gallon
of gas per person.
And Pipistrel, pictured here,
won $1.3 million and flew over
400 miles in that in that
two-hour period.
So here's an opportunity
leverage a need that we have
with funding that we have to
enable innovation in the
marketplace.
There was another entry that
broke the 200-mile barrier,
but they didn't break the 400
and a number of others that
didn't win.
But here's an example of
individuals, whether they're
partnered teams or individuals
themselves, because of the
opportunity are willing to spend
their time and their own
resources to come up with
solutions to a technological
problem that we have and hadn't
really focused on and
have a payday where,
eventually, a
company can come out.
In fact, there is a Centennial
Challenge winner for an
astronaut glove--
very difficult technology
challenge to enable an
effective glove when you're in
zero G and you've got a vacuum
that you're fighting against
and a pressurized suit.
To be able to have the ability
to grasp and use tools--
really tough.
So there was a Centennial
Challenge for that.
And now there's a company.
The winner of that Centennial
Challenge has a company that
is building suits.
So the idea here is, are there
technological challenges that
we can identify in this Grand
Challenge that we can spark
some innovation from folks that
may be not thinking about
this right now but would be
willing to spend their time
and energy for the
contribution?
Another mechanism for us in
the Grand Challenge is
crowdsourcing.
And you guys are probably
quite familiar with it.
The idea here is that you
leverage the crowd to help
with a problem.
The Zooniverse platform through
Galaxy Zoo radically
cut the time it took to
characterize and define types
of galaxies out there.
And so we have lots of data
through our asteroid search.
Planetary Resources, a mining
company, wants to exploit the
resources of asteroids, had a
Kickstarter campaign, raised
almost $2 million.
And because they raised so much,
they announced they were
going to be able to do
an Asteroid Zoo.
And so, through a partnership
with the Catalina Sky Survey--
that's a survey out of Arizona
that has years worth of data--
the thinking is, by opening up
that data to the crowd, we can
have eyeballs on that that the
algorithms might have missed,
some potentially hazardous
asteroids there.
Are there other ways that we can
use the benefit of a crowd
to help with this
data problem?
And finally, really, the fourth
area, it's related to
the light curve analysis
piece.
But it's citizen science.
And this image here
predates NASA.
I think this image
is '55 or '56.
And you're looking at
Biloxi, Mississippi,
Operation Moon Watch.
The idea was a brainchild of a
gentleman at the Smithsonian
Astrophysical Observatory and
had tremendous battles with
the science community back
then because his idea was
there are going to be all sorts
of human-made object
circling the earth, and we're
going to need to know where
they are, what they are.
And we don't have any ability
to do that right now.
So I want to go out and train
the citizenry to be able to do
to help with this effort.
And so they did that
very thing.
Here you see a training in
Biloxi where they're showing
folks how to look at
how to contribute.
And if you do a search on Moon
Watch, you'll find images--
Boy Scouts in the Philippines ,
gentlemen in suit and tie in
South Africa looking
through telescopes.
And what they'd do is they'd
find something in the sky, and
they'd let the people
in Boston know.
And they'd get the cameras out
and be able to take images.
And so before NASA was even
around, citizen science was
proving its value in
contributing to a cause.
And the essence here of the
Grand Challenge is this is
bigger than NASA's ability
to do on its own.
We don't want to do
it on our own.
The excitement of engaging
communities that we don't
normally talk with to help solve
problems that we can't
do on our own, that's the
opportunity here.
An example of how this type
of innovation can work--
we had a dark matter problem.
And through a challenge that
was thrown out to a broad
community, turns out that a
glaciologist noticed what we
were looking for and said, aha,
the edge detection and
the change for glaciers is
very similar to this dark
matter problem.
And so what happened is he
came with a solution--
would have never been involved
in a dark matter
conversation before.
And that challenge sparked
innovation from a totally
different field.
He didn't end up winning the
prize, because you ended up
having an astrophysicist that
saw the improvement and was
able to then tweak that
improvement for an even
greater improvement.
But you had breakthrough because
of a broad engagement.
And so that's really what we're
looking to do here, is
to start this global
conversation and engage in a
dialogue with citizenry of the
Earth and our national
partners around the globe.
And really, what it does is it
allows us to prove that we are
smarter than the dinosaurs.
This is, again, the one natural
disaster that we have
the ability to do
something about.
We have the science.
We have the technology.
We could have great
breakthroughs to
improve all of that.
But what a great legacy for us
to focus on in the next 10 or
15 years and potentially do it
sooner and be able to share
with our kids and our grandkids
that this is a
problem they don't have
to worry about.
There are going to
be plenty others.
But this is one that we took
ownership of and decided we
would solve together.
And so with that, I will gladly
take any questions and
hopefully spark some solutions
in the room today.
AUDIENCE: How do you know you
found 95% if you don't know
the last 5%?
JASON KESSLER: It's modeling
and statistics, so it's a
best-guess right now.
But we don't know for sure.
And so that's where I will say,
statistically, somebody
might say, it looks like the
planet killer happens every
100 million years.
It happened within
66 million years.
But that doesn't mean that we're
going to wait 30 more
million years until
it happens again.
We can only look to the way the
climate is changing and
seeing that the 500-year flood
is no longer every 500 years.
And so while we feel confident
we've got 95%, we don't know
that for sure.
And we certainly need to
increase the number that we're
finding each year.
So it's a best guess
at this point, that
we feel good about.
AUDIENCE: What your estimate
of the fraction of the
30-meter asteroids that
have been found?
JASON KESSLER: In
the 1% range.
So when you look at the models
that say there's down to 30
meters, they'll say the
population is so big.
And what we've discovered
of that estimated
population is about 1%.
So I won't quote the numbers on
that, but the frequency of
the smaller are going to
be much higher than
the 1 in 100 million.
And the other interesting thing,
because we're growing
our population so rapidly, the
numbers are going to increase
because there are going to be
more populated areas for
people to be impacted
by these.
So that's a piece, in terms of
the numbers, that folks I
don't think often consider.
AUDIENCE: Ballpark, how many
asteroids are you actually
tracking right now?
How may does 95% account for?
JASON KESSLER: We have about
10,000 that we have track of.
But one of the difficulties
with it is that
you can find it--
you might find one--
but you've got to get more glass
on it pretty quickly
because they're moving
by fast.
And so if you don't track it
well enough to understand its
orbit, it'll be gone, and you
won't know when it's coming
back or where it's
coming from.
And so there really needs to
be a concerted effort.
And I think that's where we have
an exciting opportunity
to really build a
global network.
So we've got a strong US
detection, ground-based
network currently.
Europeans are doing
great work.
There's a great opportunity in
Africa, a great opportunity to
improve Southern Hemisphere
coverage.
And so having a network when
somebody's dark versus daytime
or somebody's cloud-covered and
can't see is really where
we need to be so that we can
find them and then get
tracking on them quickly,
before they're gone.
AUDIENCE: With the one earlier
this year in Russia, did we
have any warning that
that was going to
happen, or it was a surprise?
JASON KESSLER: No.
And the difficulty there, the
attraction of a space-based
telescope that's in a Venus
orbit, is that asteroid was
coming from the sun, the
direction of the sun.
And so even if we had some
warning or ability, we would
have been blinded and not be
able to pick it up, because 17
meters is pretty small.
Yeah, so no warning.
AUDIENCE: You have the
crowd-sourced efforts like the
DNA folding and Galaxy
Zoo and all that.
What future ones do you
envision coming?
And maybe it involved asteroids,
but what other
crowd-source efforts
do you picture?
JASON KESSLER: I'll tell
you a pretty fun--
I think it gets in semantics
whether it's crowdsourcing or
citizen science, and I won't go
into the details of that--
but we had a challenge.
The longerons are the structures
on the space
station that hold the
solar arrays.
Now, the station is circling the
Earth, and it's in night
and day every 90 minutes.
And so there's a great
temperature variation.
And so are we're starting to
notice some limitations in our
ability to maximize the sunlight
that we're getting on
the solar arrays because we
don't want these longerons to
get too brittle.
And so there was a challenge
that was thrown out.
And the interesting thing about
this challenge is the
first step in the challenge
was to build a model that
would enable a full-up 3D
model of the system.
That was challenge
one, solve that.
Second challenge was to then
figure out, how do you
maximize the sunlight hitting
the arrays without
threatening--
there are a couple of particular
joints that were
areas of concern.
Crowd--
if you want to call it the
crowd, maybe expert crowd--
solved it in days.
And the solution is not yet
being implemented, but we
expect as this life of
the station continues
that it will be.
And so we're just starting to
play with this concept of the
crowd-enabling solution to
problems that we have.
And so part of the pressure that
I feel as owner of this
Grand Challenge for NASA is to
show the agency that this is a
culture change shift, that there
are smart people out
there in other fields that can
contribute to the mission and
impact and benefit the mission
just by having a conversation
and, in this and other
instances, using a challenge
to incentivize people.
But there are a lot of
mechanisms that I think I
really see this as contributing
not just at NASA
but, whether it's the aerospace
industry or industry
at large, there's an opportunity
here to see that
you can really help through
this method.
AUDIENCE: Do we think that the
asteroid that caused the K-T
event and the asteroid that
hit in Russia, were these
asteroids in near Earth
orbit that we
just didn't know about?
Or were they asteroids in highly
elliptical orbits,
trans-Neptunian objects that
this was their first time
approaching the earth in 5,000,
10,000 years, and
there's no way we could know
about them in advance?
JASON KESSLER: Had we had the
systems in place, we would
have known that these are
crossing our path and that
there's about a million of them
like that out there down
to 30 meters.
So it's a very active
neighborhood.
But that's not to say--
somebody brought up the
issue of comets.
Right now, the Asteroid
Grand Challenge
is focused on asteroids.
But comets also pose
hazard as well.
AUDIENCE: Russia, 1970.
JASON KESSLER: So it might be
worth expanding the focus.
And so that's where I would
say that some of the
discomfort is that we've got
some plan right now, but
having a conversation leads us
into saying, oh, yeah, what
about that?
We need to add that.
And that's not habitual
for us at the agency.
So this is fun to
be playing in.
AUDIENCE: So that's a perfect
prelude into my question.
I think that this is a great
example, and I think the comet
one would be another
great example.
But there are very few people
qualified to take a lot of
these problems end to end.
How much work is being done to
take the base problem, the
fundamental problem, and get
them in the hands of kids or
people that aren't as qualified,
getting them to
where the experts can focus
on the last mile?
JASON KESSLER: Sure.
And this one in particular, as
NASA's first Grand Challenge--
so the White House sees Grand
Challenges and as a means of
innovation.
This is a strategic method
of innovation.
So DOE has a couple of
Grand Challenges.
USAID has a couple of
The Brain Initiative that was
recently announced this year
is also a Grand.
Challenge
The Asteroid Grand Challenge
is scientifically and
technically tough.
There's no doubt.
We issued a request for
information back on the 18th
in June when we announced
the Grand Challenge.
And that request for information
was open for 30
days, and as things are, this
was released through Fed Biz
Ops and the traditional
NASA methods.
We got over 402 responses, a lot
of which were from folks
we don't normally talk with.
We had 96 of those responses
that we are gathering the
proposers, either virtually or
in person in Houston at the
end of the month-- and I'll
invite you to watch, because
we'll be broadcasting live--
to bring together those ideas.
And in some of those ideas,
there is the opportunity to
have telescope farms.
So I was in a conversation
last week.
And I'd lived in Manhattan for
seven years, and it didn't
even dawn on me.
One of the opportunities here
is you're talking about
getting into the hands
of everybody.
People in the city
aren't going to
get a backyard telescope.
They're not even going to spend
$10,000, $15,000 to get
a system that would enable them
to do light curve work
let alone have the time and
the willingness to dig in.
But could you imagine a
crowd-funded or crowd-shared
set of telescopes in ideal
places all over the world
where that student or that
mom chooses to spend a
subscription fee and participate
that way, either
buying the time so that she can
look or donating that time
to others so that
they can look?
And so that's an initial
reaction.
Just out of the first request
in June, we're getting ideas
on how to enable the citizenry
to engage.
I would say that the biggest
hurdle is going to be in
mitigation.
Detection, tracking,
characterization, it's a
little easier to get one's arms
around how people would
contribute there.
But mitigation's tough.
You don't have to move it a
whole lot, but you've still
got to move it.
And technically, that's
not an easy task.
And so that's where I think
there will be less opportunity
for most folks to be
able to contribute.
But whether it's looking
through a Galaxy Zoo or
whether it's contributing
through a
crowd-funded effort--
the other thing from my
perspective and why I'm happy
to talk to anybody about this
is that who knows what
network they have?
So you speak to somebody.
Now they go home and talk to
their spouse, their friends.
And somebody gets turned on by
the ideas, and they have a
whole network that they can
bring into this conversation.
So even if it's just talking
about it, from my perspective,
that's a contribution.
AUDIENCE: Great.
JASON KESSLER: Well, thank you
so very much for having me.
And I invite you to watch
through the Asteroid
Initiative page--
we're having the workshop at
the end of the month, 96
fantastic ideas from folks that
are wanting to go explore
asteroids and protect the
planet from them--
and encourage you to talk
amongst your networks and
friends about this very issue.
So, thank you.
Take good care.
[APPLAUSE]